of those 10 things you've mentioned
could you now tell us which is
considered to be the most serious and
sinful act which invalidates the fast
the ACT which is the most sinful and
most serious amongst all of them which
invalidate the fast it is sexual
intercourse that when you have sexual
intercourse and when the two private
parts meet then your fast is
invalidated whether ejaculation takes
place or not and you have to repent for
that you have to complete the fast for
that day and you have to make it up
later and you have to pay a penalty
that's kafar according to the sayth in
which a beloved Prophet said it's
mentioned
inkari volume number three in the book
of fasting Hadith number 1936 where a
man comes to the prophet and says that I
am ruined oh Prophet I ruined the
prophet says what is the matter the man
says I had sex with my wife while I was
fasting so the prophet says that can you
free a slave so the man say no I
cannot then the prophet asked Can you
fast consecutively for two months can
you fast continuously for 60 days the
man says no I cannot then the prophet
says that
that can you feed 60 poor
people and the man says no and the
Hadith continues in short we come to
know from this Hadith that if any person
does a sexual intercourse it is one of
the major sins it is the most serious
and sinful amongst all the things that
break the fast the person who does this
sin he should immediately repent to
Allah subhana wa tala and ask for
forgiveness he should complete his fast
for that day and make up for that fast
later on after Ramadan and he has to pay
a penalty and the penalty we come from
this Hadith is that he either frees a
slave if he can if he does not have the
money to free the slave or he cannot
find a slave to free then he should fast
for two consecutive
months fast for 60 days if you cannot do
that also then you should at least feed
60 poor
people and these are the three options
that have been given for a person to pay
as a penalty as a kafara but if a person
can do the first thing he should not
jump to the second or the third the
first is freeing a slave if he cannot do
that if he doesn't have the money or
cannot find a slave then he can go to
the next option that is fasting
consecutively for 60 days if he cannot
do that if he's unable to do that
continuously fasting for 60 days if he
fast for a few days and then one day
doesn't fast he should start again he
should fast consecutively for 60 days if
he doesn't have the capacity to do that
then what he can do is he can feed 60
poor people and each poor person should
be fed with approximately half s each s
is equal to three handful of all
stretched hand of feet so half s per
person all the food that is there of the
land so 60 poor people who should feed
this is the kafar
the penalty for a person who breaks a f
by having a sexual
intercourse the amount of food just to
clarify that for my own benefit if you
like do you think that that's equivalent
to about a day's food approxim in short
it should be a day food that's normal in
that land it may change in America it
may change in UK it may change in India
but at that time it was like one had the
says that one man re half South Meat and
each South meat is outstretched two
hands if outstretch and the amount of
weed that comes in that's equal to S so
half of three the other Hadith says that
one mud of meat that is equal to one
outstretched hand of wheat say that
equivalent to fill a poor man's appetite
you know his stomach so in short you
should feed a poor person 60 poor people
you should
feed approximately what is the food of
that land that you should feed him and
if you can't find people in your land
who are poor then you look for the
nearest place or yes anywhere and that's
difficult in today's world that you
cannot find 60 people to feed I don't
know any place in the world where you
cannot find 60 people to feed it may not
be a locality but if you just go to the
next locality in your city surely in
your country surely you can find I wish
to Allah subhana tal made that time come
aan aan which will come insh inshallah
in